[Musique]
et avec notre invité la question
d'économie solidaire par certains
d'inflation galopante bonjour Nicolas
Chabanne et pour diriger cette interview
avec moi Christophe dans cette
chroniqueur économie à France 24 bonjour
Christophe
Nicolas Chabanne fondateur donc de ce
qu'ils patron quelques chiffres pour
commencer une coopérative de
consommateurs devenu un acteur majeur de
l'économie en France en seulement 6 ans
12200 sociétaires qui soutiennent la
démarche 15 millions de consommateurs
100 millions de produits et solidaires
vendus chaque année 32 références la
brique de lait la plus vendue en France
vous l'avez devant vous sur ce plateau
c'est celle que vous produisez quel est
Nicolas Chabanne la clé de ce succès
alors que l'économie n'est pas
franchement au mieux de sa forme
alors on a parlé tout à l'heure juste
avant de démarrer cette interview un
documentaire en ce moment est tourné sur
l'aventure mais la question qui nous est
posée c'est comment de simples
consommateurs sans débrouiller habituel
des grandes marques sans de la pub
massive à la télévision sans commerciaux
dans les magasins a réussi à vendre
autant de produits solidaires tous
cesquitable je crois que la réponse elle
se retrouve sur un autre chemin que les
chemins habituels de l'économie et des
règles de l'économie on est nous
consommateurs porteur de l'essentiel
dans nos poches l'argent qu'il façonnent
chaque jour et l'économie et le monde
qui nous entoure c'est un moment donné
on est sensible comme ça a été le cas au
sort des producteurs on a envie à en
acheter un brique de lait que leur
journée soit éclairée autrement que dans
des doutes et dans des angoisses comme
il l'avait pendant 40 ans ça devient
cette brique de lait solidaire équitable
qui devient numéro un des ventes au-delà
des chiffres c'est l'espoir pour les
producteurs ils en ont énormément besoin
aujourd'hui et merci à tous ceux qui
permettent ce grand succès solidaire
elle a elle a un prix aussi on parle
d'inflation on va voir le chiffre
là-dedans dans une demi-heure de
l'inflation du mois d'octobre et nul
doute qui sera autour encore une fois de
6 % économie solidaire ça coûte un petit
peu plus cher alors comment ça se passe
comment vous faites vous en ce moment
alors c'est vrai que normalement en
période d'inflation on aurait dû voir
les ventes de ces produits solidaires
qui soutiennent directement les
producteurs se contracter ou baisser
c'est tellement étonnant et c'est une
tellement incroyable nouvelle les ventes
progressent elles n'ont jamais été aussi
haute c'est à dire que cette brique de
lait qui était déjà numéro un des ventes
elle a accentué son niveau de vente et
donc de soutien en producteur et on doit
vous préciser une chose on a un nouveau
que certains de vos confrères ont fait
une étude et sont rendus compte que
lorsque les produits du rayon laitier
avait pris 15 à 20% à cause de
l'inflation
cette brique de lait par exemple a pris
4%. pourquoi parce que en dessous du
niveau de
quand vous payez au juste prix depuis 6
ans les producteurs au moment où il y a
se rattrapage qui se fait il y a un
effet d'amortissement donc finalement
est-ce que ces produits solidaires créés
par nous les consommateurs c'est pas un
horizon un peu différent le juste prix
il est moins dépendant évidemment des
fluctuations du marché Nicolas Chavanne
vous dites que la carte bancaire c'est
le bulletin de vote le plus puissant
pour changer le monde vous voulez que le
consommateur sache où va son argent
est-ce que vous y parvenez
oui je peux le dire aussi simplement
lorsque vous créez une démarche comme
celle là vous devenez sociétaire demain
non seulement vous créez les produits
mais vous challengez votre marque de
consommateur vous avez pas envie d'être
dans une logique de communication de
marque et qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
tout les mois voir les producteurs nous
les consommateurs pas simplement les
gens du bureau n'importe quelle société
et on demande les unes dans les yeux à
un producteur est-ce que les centimes
qui nous sont promis là par la petite
phrase il vous parviennent bien
qu'est-ce que ça change pour vous quand
un producteur les yeux dans les yeux
vous dis vous n'imaginez pas ce que
c'est comme soutien moralement
financièrement vous êtes payé tous vos
efforts et vous vérifiez évidemment que
c'est bien une réalité aujourd'hui on
est tous pareils dans une situation
comme celle-là la question c'est ouvert
notre argent cet argent il façonne
encore une fois le monde qui nous
entoure donc ce destin qui est un peu
impressionnant et qui nous échappe à
partir de nos achats on est capable de
reprendre ce volant collectivement c'est
ça que prouve cette histoire et on
essaye d'ailleurs de faire en sorte que
d'autres pas simplement ce qui est le
patron mais mieux les producteurs on n'a
pas envie que ce soit la marque la plus
vendue on veut que ce soit des valeurs
qu'on retrouve même dans d'autres
entreprises vous avez aujourd'hui 32
valeurs 32 produits pardon le
filomi le rappeler à l'instant 32
produits est-ce que il y a une suite
est-ce que ce sera plus est-ce que ça va
rester simplement dans le domaine de
l'alimentaire ou est-ce que vous avez
peut-être envie d'aller sur d'autres
domaines encore on a beaucoup de
demandes pour étendre ce succès
solidaire vers d'autres secteurs mais
d'abord on veut que les producteurs et
tous les producteurs en France pas
simplement certains bénéficie il y a
3000 familles qui sont aidé par la
démarche il y en a des milliers d'autres
qui attendent et prochainement on
devrait pouvoir annoncer quelque chose
d'important c'est le nom d'une autre
marque nous consommateurs on a dit à aux
entreprises s'il y a une marque qui est
capable d'être à la hauteur de ses
attentes très bienveillantes mais
transparence solidarité partage de la
valeur création de la valeur qui nous
explique bien autour chaque centimes et
bien à ce moment là on en fera une
grande publicité dans quelques dans
quelques jours on va pouvoir annoncer le
nom de cette autre entreprise parce
qu'encore une fois il faut pas que c'est
qui le patron reste tout seul il faut
que d'autres entreprises reprennent les
clés de cette solidarité pour le
développer ni quoi nous sommes sur une
chaîne internationale est-ce que c'est
qui le patron a des équivalents à
l'étranger oui il y a 8 pays
en Espagne qui est né sales référent en
Allemagne de Bessières d'un chef des
consommateurs vous avez ce petit logo
avec un dénomination différente des
consommateurs dans chaque pays se sont
dit mais est-ce que c'est bien différent
chez nous est-ce qu'on a pas envie nous
consommateurs que cet argent pas facile
à gagner soit investi au bon endroit et
voilà comment huit pays ont développé
des démarches similaires et je crois que
ce bon sens collectif c'est
bienveillance elle est assez universelle
pour que cette démarche devienne
internationale et on l'espère se
généralise et qu'en est-il de l'Afrique
je pense que je crois que vous êtes né
où vous en tout cas j'ai passé une
partie de votre jeunesse jusqu'à 7 ans
en Afrique à Madagascar pour être précis
la question de la rémunération des
producteurs c'est une question
extrêmement importante en Afrique je
pense notamment au café ou au chocolat
pour des pays comme de la Côte d'Ivoire
que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire est-ce qu'on peut faire davantage
pour ces producteurs africains il faut
faire l'avantage
parce qu'on fait du commerce équitable
Nord avec cette démarche on n'oublie pas
le commerce équitable historique
Nord-Sud il y a un chocolat c'est qui le
patron et c'était étonnant mais on s'est
dit écoutez on veut pas s'arrêter à ce
qu'on nous dit on est allé jusqu'en Côte
d'Ivoire voir au-delà de la coopérative
qui parfois explique que tout va bien on
est allé voir jusqu'au producteur
parfois des producteurs sont pas
forcément destinataires de chaque
centime et là et ça n'allait pas on
s'est rendu compte qu'avec des petites
choses à régler c'est là où c'est
intéressant la démarche on a demandé aux
fabricants de faire le nécessaire et ça
y est on est sûr quand on achète ce
chocolat que vont bien jusqu'au
producteurs qu'on a rencontré avec des
programmes de soutien pour leur famille
c'est très simple souvent il faudra
appeler 8 centimes pour la boîte de
Violaine 9 pour le jus de pomme très
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui un consommateur quel qu'il
soit allemand
béninois camerounais américain japonais
n'importe qu'est-ce que vous lui dites
aujourd'hui dans Dans le cadre de votre
démarche ce qu'on peut dire à tout le
monde à chaque consommateur chaque
citoyen de n'importe quel pays du monde
c'est que vraiment il y a dans ce moment
très compliqué où on a l'impression que
notre destin nous échappe un peu il est
entre les mains notamment les politiques
on a
l'élément clé la clé de la solution
c'est ce sont nos actes d'achat vous
l'avez dit si un moment donné on
prononce le on se rassemblent nous les
citoyens à partir de quelque chose de
simple et bienveillant et qu'on amène
nos notre argent vers les entreprises
au-delà de celle-là qui paient bien leur
salarié qui crée de la valeur qui
recréent la transparence mécaniquement
ce monde qui nous entoure ira mieux
parce que l'argent conditionne
évidemment les impacts environnementaux
sociaux à tous les niveaux ce qui est
aujourd'hui dans nos poches isolé ces
quelques centaines d'euros rassemblés on
est un groupe milliardaire mondial on
est les plus puissants qui soient avec
un grand sourire encore une fois
beaucoup de bienveillance que les
citoyens se rassemblent pour organiser
un commerce un peu différent à partir de
leur acte d'achat absolument incroyable
et on se demande comment cette idée elle
vous est venue parce que vous étiez pas
du tout destiné à vous lancer dans
l'agroalimentaire comme ça je pense que
vous étiez
plutôt dans
la question des voitures du lavage de
voiture comme comment est-ce que vous
êtes arrivés à ce changement radical au
départ des centres de lavage auto
c'était au tout début c'était pour aider
des gens effectivement qui trouvaient
pas de boulot et ensuite
j'ai des copains en classe qui étaient
des des fils de producteurs notamment de
fraises ils étaient en difficulté chaque
jour il bossait beaucoup il m'a raconté
leur weekend qui était pas des week-end
de vacances et moi j'avais une petite
envie de communiquer pour eux voilà je
voulais le dire à leur place et c'est
comme ça que dans ce rôle de
porte-parole donc la brique de lait nous
est apparue comme quelque chose qui
condamnait à l'autre bout les
producteurs rendez compte on a acheté
avec notre argent le monde était
incroyable et injuste notre argent
servait à alimenter un système qui
rendait malheureux des producteurs en a
dit stop on a créé la brique de lait
c'était émotionnel et simple et c'est
devenu la brique de lait la plus vendue
en France et on espère que cette
démarche va se généraliser il y a
beaucoup de constructeur a aidé ils sont
en difficulté aujourd'hui et n'oublions
pas une chose c'est que ces producteurs
nous nourrissent c'est pas simplement
des gens encore une fois qu'ils sont
dans un coin de décor de l'économie il
ne nourrit chaque jour et il faut les
aider à nourrir mon argent mon pouvoir
un dernier mot qui se trouve dans cette
ferme je pense qu'on peut refermer parce
que c'était une super conclusion que
vous avez fait parfait merci beaucoup à
vos Christophe dans cette Merci à VOUS
Nicolas Chabanne d'être venu jusqu'à
nous patrons de ce qui le patron c'était
l'invité de Paris direct l'information
internationale et française continue sur
nos chaînes rester avec nous